[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com alabama Republican Senate
candidate and sort of all-around
horrible person
Roy Moore has been accused of sexual
assault by a fourteen-year-old girl and
the entire race has imploded or been
blown wide open I guess it depends which
catchphrase you want to use and the
backstory of course is that we've had
this very interesting Alabama Senate
race between former judge Roy Moore
who's running for the seat vacated by
Donald Trump's Attorney General Jeff
Sessions which is now now an empty seat
special election Democrat Doug Jones is
running against Roy Moore pretty good
candidate Moore is absolutely nutty some
of mors greatest hits include saying
that the First Amendment protects
Christians only one said that he
believed he might ultimately give his
life to try to stop gay marriage which
would be a really stupid thing to say
and an even dumber thing to do can you
imagine giving your life to stop gay
marriage and over the weekend the race
was blown open when it leaked that Roy
Moore initiated sexual contact with a 14
year old girl when he was in his 30s and
Lee Kaufman says she was 14 when Roy
Moore then thirty two years old drove
Kaufman to his home in the woods told
her she was really pretty and kissed her
just horrible right it's all it's
already vile on their next visit he
allegedly took off her shirt and pants
removed his own clothes touched her over
her bra and Underpants and guided her
hand to touch him over his underwear and
the story has been corroborated by
childhood friends of course means who
said she told us the exact same thing at
the time there are three other women
aged 16 to 18 who also said that Roy
Moore was pursuing relationships with
them when he was in his 30s although
given the age of consent in Alabama and
the fact
they didn't feel forced those are not
key parts of the most disturbing
allegations here and more is doing the
full monty denial
each denial with even less credibility
he denied the allegations he blamed The
Washington Post which initially reported
these claims for basically doing a smear
campaign on him he blamed the Democratic
Party for participating in the smear
campaign I guess claiming that it's all
fake news and there are actually some
Republicans defending Roy Moore there's
this guy named Jim Ziegler who's the
Alabama state auditor he told the
Washington Examiner late last week in
arguably one of the most disgusting and
bizarre uses of the Bible to defend
child sexual assault
Ziegler tried to use Jesus to defend
more sexually assaulting a
fourteen-year-old girl by saying take
Joseph and Mary Mary was a teenager and
Joseph was an adult carpenter they
became parents of Jesus which doesn't
really make too much sense I mean I
think the whole point was Jesus's mother
never had sex so there would have been
no instance where she was having sex
with some guy who was too old because it
was a virgin birth right it was
Immaculate Conception or whatever the
folks call it these days I can't really
say too much else about it right I mean
if I need to explain to you why that's
nutty I'm probably not going to change
your mind then we had Alabama Secretary
of State John Merrill who told Think
Progress late last week quote I don't
know how much validity the claims have
the claims have to them we had Mobile
County Republican chairman John skipper
who said it does not really surprise me
I think that it is a typical Democratic
Democrat play to discredit judge Moore a
sincere honest trustworthy individual
and there are some Republicans sort of
carefully saying that if the allegations
are true Moore has to step aside
Republican Mitt Romney just flat-out
said Roy Moore is unfit for office and
should step aside interesting but do
Alabamans who would consider voting for
Roy Moore really care what Mitt Romney
has to say about it probably not
although it's interesting nonetheless
and then as far as voters the reality is
that if you thought that this guy might
be a good senator
a really good chance you're not going to
be influenced by child sexual assault
charges and in fact this morning CNN was
interviewing Alabama voters and a lot of
them too said hey we don't believe it or
he has a lifelong credential of being a
man of God and these are just
allegations from some 14-year old kid
and the real hypocrisy to me is Moore's
history of declaring himself the moral
champion the arbiter of family values
and many Republicans do see him that way
Moore refused to remove a wooden tablet
of the Ten Commandments from behind his
bench on the court he wanted to install
a Ten Commandment stone monument on the
Alabama Supreme Court building and
Colter declared him man of the year
whatever that means said he's a great
defender of conservative values
conservative Review named Moore man of
the year for refusing to allow gay
marriage in Alabama of course Moore was
ultimately suspended for that and
resigned it's a long list and the
fascinating thing about this is that it
puts Moore's views against statutory
rape laws in a whole new light there
have been cases where Roy Moore
previously argued that an adult having
sex with someone below the age of
consent right statutory rape under the
law wasn't rape if the adult didn't
threaten or attack the victim which is
not the way statutory rape laws work
there was a case where Moore was the
only vote in favor of a day care worker
who raped the twelve-year-old claiming
that there was no implied threat of
serious physical injury and what this
tells us is not only that Moore himself
is a hypocrite and that maybe his
positions on statutory rape were
self-serving to a degree that we only
now are learning this also tells us that
religious conservatism although it
presents itself as being all about
undying and respectable ethics or
whatever it has no real underlying
ethics it's all about winning and it's
all about holding back those evil
leftists when you see these Alabama
Republicans saying even if it's true he
lived a life of a man of God and I'm
still going to vote for the guy very
very strange and how is this affecting
the race well we'll talk about that a
little bit later in the program now as
if the Roy Moore situation wasn't bad
enough Sean Hannity Fox News host
weirdly seemed to argue that everything
Roy Moore did was consensual which
ignores this little thing the serious
thing that I call statutory rape and now
advertisers are just running away they
are fleeing from Hannity's program
including one advertiser that I think is
going to help Pat out quite a bit in
terms of a recent scandal that he's been
wrapped up in I'll get more more about
that in a moment after the Roy Moore
allegations surfaced the right-wing
media machine machine kicked into high
gear and it's often the case that they
do this to defend the indefensible and
in comes Sean Hannity he's interviewing
Linda mcLaughlin I don't know who that
is but that's who he's interviewing and
it is bad bad bad when Sean Hannity says
hey listen this was all consensual after
all which ignores as I said this thing
called statutory rape take a listen to
this how do you possibly tell no the
truth except okay so the two other girls
were older in this case he was
apparently like 32 okay and he dated one
girl was 18 one girl was 17 they never
said he did it there's no sexual was
kissing involved and then they're saying
this one in town with a four-channel and
consensual that's true and there's you
know I just I don't know how you find
out the truth so it's a little ambiguous
right it kind of seems like Sean Hannity
is commenting on the fourteen-year-old
girl having been involved in something
that was consensual although some others
are saying no he was only saying that 16
to 18 year old girls were consensual and
they're above the age of consent and
Hannity says right oh yeah it was
consensual so my initial thought was
well is this another one of these
legitimate rape moments right is it was
it really statutory rape
because whatever Hannity thinks of as
consensual is what it was was it a
semantic thing I don't know but as a
reminder the basis of sexual consent
laws are that a person who is a minor by
definition by statute cannot legally
consent period as a society we've
determined that no matter what the
fourteen-year-old thinks they want to do
they're not mature enough to really be
able to make that
call now this exploded rightly so and
then Sean Hannity ended up having to do
not one but two apologies one was on
Twitter and one was on his show and
after the show one he went on Twitter
and said as I said on TV tonight
I apologize when I misspoke and was not
totally clear earlier today and then
went on to criticize the media similar
statement on his program about this but
it was too late
right the advertisers are running away
from Hannity after they ran away from
Bill O'Reilly's program some time ago
during his downfall on Fox News
genetic testing company 23andme which I
used for our DNA test segment some time
ago
they're bailing from the Hannity show
they tweeted we've received enquiries
regarding advertising on Hannity we are
not running TV advertising on Hannity we
continue to closely evaluate where we
advertise realtor.com says that they're
out they sent out a bunch of tweets to
people saying that they've pulled the ad
placements on the Hannity program they
since deleted those tweets I don't know
what was the PR strategy behind that but
one example of the tweets from
realtor.com Twitter account thanks for
bringing this to our attention we are
adjusting our media by who no longer
include this show placement and then
curate the coffee maker company that
uses pods famous on this program because
producer Pat uses it and has suffered at
the hands of many audience members as a
result of his use they are out out out
tweeting Angelo - Angelo carosone who I
know by the way interestingly enough
Angelo thank you for your concern and
for bringing this to our attention we
worked with our media partner and Fox
News to stop our ad from airing during
the sean hannity show the keurig thing
has set people off I've got the Eggman
tweeting to me about it I've got people
saying Pat has been vindicated as a
result of this do you feel vindicated by
Keurig pulling ads from Hannity totally
vindicated I feel like I've weathered
the storm and I came out on top it's a
great feeling the crazy thing is Pat was
being criticized because Keurig makes
bad coffee not because anyone said it's
a bad company and somehow now the fact
that they've pulled the Hannity ads is
helping Pat which we'll take I'm sure
I'm gonna buy a new one put it in the
studio maybe
yeah Pat's bring it Pat actually has an
order for a dozen Carrick's they're
gonna be lined up behind me
on the set but the kirik thing has set
people off somehow the defense of child
sexual predators led to a cancellation
of ads by Keurig which has led to
conservatives posting videos of
themselves smashing their Keurigs in
protest of Keurigs decision and this is
where we are in politics right now I'm
not gonna play any of the videos of
right-wingers destroying their Keurig
makers because I don't want to give them
any attention you can google it and find
lots of examples of it all well and good
ideally these companies wouldn't have
been advertising on Sean Hannity's
program in the first place but progress
is progress and the real question here
is and you know I would get to it how is
the ROI more sec child sexual assault
scandal affecting the race since this is
an opportunity to take out a reliable
red seat and put a Democrat in possibly
Democrat Doug Jones let's go to the
latest polling so we had these these
revelations about Roy Moore Republican
Senate candidate in Alabama running for
Jeff Sessions a seat accused of child
sexual assault by a then 14-year old we
talked about sean hannity and other
republican defenders we talked about
people like mitt romney saying the guy
is unfit he's got to step down but how
is it impacting the race well we have a
new senate poll where democrat doug
jones is leading republican roy more in
the state of alabama in the race for
donald trump's attorney general jeff
sessions is old senate seat this is the
first poll that shows doug jones having
a lead
it has Jones up 46 to 42 this poll was
done by JMC analytics after the
reporting of the child sex assault
allegations surfaced against Roy Moore
now it's 46 42 but it has a 4% margin of
error so statistically this is still a
high and my concern is is there an
element of the Bradley effect if the
Bradley effect is real not everybody
believes that the Bradley effect is real
the Bradley effect is the idea that you
might have people who are afraid or
embarrassed to tell pollsters that
they're still planning to vote for the
alleged
child sexual assault er and it was named
after Tom Bradley who was the former
african-american mayor of Los Angeles
and in 1982 he ran for governor of
California and he was depending on what
you look at either slightly ahead or
doing well in the polls on Election Day
or exit polls on Election Day were
showing him ahead and he ultimately lost
and this was attributed by many people
to the idea that they weren't really
gonna vote for a black guy and they
wouldn't vote for a black guy but they
wanted to appear to be not racist
something called the social desirability
bias where people are more likely to
answer questions the way they believe
would would see them most favorably
viewed by society however there are
people who say there's no such thing as
the Bradley effect they say no what
happened was a lot of Republicans voted
absentee in California and 82 so the
exit polls were heavily skewed towards
the in-person voters who were Democrats
so that there was not actually this
Bradley effect anyway it's not
universally accepted but that's one
question right when you see a lot of
undecideds and there's close to 10
percent undecided in this poll you might
wonder well are people just not willing
to say I'm still going to vote for the
child sex assault er we'll see we'll see
and in fact there are some other polls
and there was another poll that came out
from decision desk HQ which has it at 46
46 with fewer undecideds there are other
polls which still have Roy Moore
slightly ahead what's clear though is
that more support has gone down now the
other thing I do want to mention is that
there's an internal here from the JMC
analytics poll which shows that 37% of
evangelical Christians that were
surveyed 37% say they are more likely to
vote for Roy Moore after news broke of
his child sexual assault allegations and
that gets me to something that I was
hoping wouldn't be true but it's not
hugely shocking which is that look
evangelicals voted for Trump when Trump
is ostensibly the opposite of what
evangelical Christians really should be
voting for and they are still going to
mostly vote for Roy Moore as well there
are
Alabama Republicans who are going to be
in the position which for them will be
very difficult of having to decide am I
more repulsed by voting for an alleged
child sex abuse er or am I more repulsed
by voting for a Democrat and for many
Alabama Republicans as we are we are
already seeing from voter interviews
that are being done by CNN and others a
lot of them would rather vote for the
alleged child sex abuse er than for a
Democrat and fundamentally Roy Moore is
what Republicans are more than we'd like
to admit and I think that we've got to
come to terms with that and just get
involved in this race to the extent that
we can I've been saying it for months
right do it phone bank donate knock on
doors if you live in Alabama because
taking this seat away from Republicans
would be so huge no matter what happens
in 2018 right strategically
mathematically we can figure all that
out
but the idea that Trump already regrets
hiring Jeff Sessions because he wants
somebody who's not recused from the
Russia stuff as Attorney General if on
top of that Donald Trump's decision to
hire Jeff Sessions led to a Democrat
taking this Alabama seat that would just
be so great I would absolutely love it
so get involved in this race donate bone
Bank do whatever you can send me your
thoughts on Twitter about it I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is justin sanchez Justin thank you
thanks for supporting our show we depend
on the support of everybody from Justin
Sanchez to all of our other members you
can sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership you can also make a pledge of
as little as a dollar a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show of
course when we get to 2500 patrons we
will produce edit and release a dozen
long-form lectures from my classes at
Boston College that's when we get to
2500 patrons we're close to 20 100 right
now okay so let's get going with our
Jenga pieces quick backstory we have
been doing this thing where when people
make contributions at patreon.com slash
david pakman show for every two
contributions I move a Jenga piece we
have currently moved 21 pieces that
corresponds by doubling that number 21
becomes a 42 percent membership discount
code if I am unable to move any more
pieces whatever the final number of
pieces I can move before the Jenga tower
falls that number gets doubled and we
create a membership discount so I we've
got five pieces to move today and I'm
gonna get right into it Pat's gonna help
me out with the names of the people and
I I'm worried today it's going to fall
but let's get right into it Pat who are
the first two names Johan Bartling and
Rick Norse okay Johan and Rick is there
a piece here that I can easily move
without it getting to here's one I've
got from the top all right one we are
now up to 22 pieces what are the next
two names
David headings and Tegan litte cot David
and Tegan all right let's see if there's
a piece here it is really getting to the
bottom now wow that one is that that's
not a good one to move here's one very
very carefully and you can see how
carefully I am doing this because we are
at 22 pieces and I am just sliding it
out and we are at 23 pieces a 46 percent
discount Pat what are the next two names
we got Richard Davis and Corey Easterday
Richard and Corey
let's see if I can find a piece to move
oh my this is getting Pat is nervous
over there Pat is really really nervous
here it is and that is now 24 or which
gets us a 48 percent discount what are
the next two names
Imelda West and Christina hassle bad
Imelda and Christina
Imelda and Christina what could I do
what about this one oh wow and that one
goes on top and that is now 25 pieces a
50% discount if I'm unable to go further
Pat what are the next two names last
ones Darrell Takhar and Michael Lyon
Darrell and Michael will Darrell Darrell
and Michael be the end of this wow I
don't know if it's smart to pull one
from the bottom but I've done it almost
oh and the entire thing just moved and I
am placing it on top which gets us to 26
moves a fifty-two percent discount if it
were to fall it continues are you
shocked that it's gone this far yeah and
it could just fall during the course of
the show too
yeah and if that if it happens during
the course of the Joad show just from my
gesticulate ng then it will still be the
52 percent membership discount all right
so contribute to the Jenga game by going
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
and making a contribution and will
continue tomorrow and see how long this
nonsense can go on okay the Trump
administration may be the death of
common sense it may be the death of
America as a steward of the environment
it may be the death of critical thinking
it could be the end of many things under
the Trump administration but it's also
in a way the end of satire and parody
I've already talked about Saturday Night
Live Saturday Night Live's job and they
do it really well
is very tough because the real world has
become almost indistinguishable from the
most extreme Saturday Night Live
parodies that they can come up with
under the presidency of Donald Trump and
Trump advisor Kellyanne Conway has now
said seemingly with no trace of irony or
satire whatsoever about the Roy Moore
sexual assault allegations that anyone
in a
that office who committed sexual assault
should resign and of course her boss the
President of the United States committed
sexual assault and he's the president
and she's certainly not calling for his
resignation at least not directly she
kept being asked by ABC's Martha Raddatz
should Roy Moore step aside and she
refused to answer that question but
instead did say that she's been clear
that anyone who commit sexual assault
should resign let's build up to it
here's a first clip of Kellyanne Conway
no reference to the Bowling Green
massacre in this clip but she did talk
about other things for more let's bring
in counselor to the president and one of
his top advisors Kellyanne Conway her
voice among those advising Donald Trump
as he decides whether to reject Roy
Moore and good morning Kellyanne The
Washington Post story is now three days
old you've had time to digest it time to
look through it do you have any doubt
about the veracity of those accusations
I said very early in this process that
the conduct as described should
disqualify anyone from serving in public
office and I'll stand by that the
President and others in the Republican
Party have made clear that if the
allegations are true this man should
step aside but I've gone farther than
that and I've reflected something the
vice president said as well which is
everybody should know that conduct is
disqualifying right so it's all
disqualifying conduct but what about
resignations and here's the big time one
and again no trace of irony when
Kellyanne Conway says anyone should step
down explicit here I denounce that
conduct and if the allegations are true
he should step aside and if the
allegations are true about a lot of
people they ought to step aside and some
of them are probably holding office let
me tell you what
wellyes Kellyanne many of them are
holding office right now one of them is
your boss that's really a statement from
Kellyanne that will really grab you by
the something and make you look really
closely at it she wants to talk about
Bob Menendez Democrat and Bill Clinton
Democrat right what about Donald Trump
what about the current president who has
been accused by endless women of sexual
assault and the bigger question is why
ask Kellyanne Conway anything at this
point right she has absolutely
no internal set of values beyond getting
paid to parrot whatever she's told to
say if we're actually going to be
serious about getting every sexual
assault er out of office you kind of
have to start at the top with Trump
himself and there's a video you can
check it out for yourself and evaluate
the credibility there's video of a woman
using the name Katy Jay who claims that
Donald Trump tied raped and tied to beat
and raped her apparently in that order
although not necessarily also threatened
hurt with murder when she was 13 years
old don't take my word for it right
check out the video which I've watched a
couple of times she seems relatively
credible and if you want to write her
off as many of many of the Trump
supporters are doing there's more than a
dozen other women right so if you really
stand by that Kellyanne how can you
ignore the reality that Donald Trump
should be at the top of the list and
this is what I'm talking about when I
say that satire is being killed by the
Trump administration the Saturday Night
Live sketches around these characters
Sarah Huckabee Sanders and Trump himself
and Kellyanne Conway Sean Spicer the
entire thing they're great right they're
brilliant from a comedic perspective but
they're in no way giving you the
impression that it could never actually
be that crazy because it's actually that
crazy it's gotten as crazy as Saturday
Night Live in the actual real Trump
White House and it's a real problem for
Saturday Night Live in a sense although
hey I'm not criticizing their ability to
put together funny sketches by any means
Kellyanne come on just say that it
applies to Trump as well
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forums at david pakman.com
slash ree
we'll take a break and be back right
after this the david pakman show at
david pakman.com welcome back to the
David Pakman show
welcoming to the program today James
Howard Kunstler who's author of the
geography of nowhere the long emergency
too much magic and the for book world
made by hand novel series he also has a
twice weekly blog and podcasts can be
found at Kunstler dot-com so let's talk
I want to talk about New Urbanism with
you but I think maybe just to get our
audience sort of into this and your work
what are some of the main concerns you
have sort of about how at least the
United States is organized
geographically in terms of cities
suburbs rural areas etc what are some of
the top-level things that we should be
thinking about well you know I have my
new theory of history which is that
things happen because they seem like a
good idea at the time
and suburban izing America in the mid
20th century seemed like a good idea at
the time and it's become extremely
problematical you know the way that we
are inhabiting the terrain of North
America especially considering the
resource problems we face and the
problems with capital or let's say
wealth or you know our accumulated
savings and we're facing a situation
that is you know we're gonna we're gonna
be short of resources especially energy
resources and the interventions of our
central banks have really impaired
capital formation so there's going to be
a lot less money to deal with the
problems we're facing well some of those
so some of the sort of factors you talk
about impact much more than just sort of
the urban rural suburban landscape I'd
be interested to hear a little more
as we can start digging in now you know
we saw this move from the city into the
creation of suburbs some decades ago
we're now starting to see and have been
seeing for 10 or 15 years the resurgence
of cities and that has led to
gentrification it's led to some cities
including where we are Boston
Massachusetts New York another example
San Francisco becoming incredibly
expensive and we're now learning all of
the problems that that brings as it
connects to wealth inequality so
specifically can you talk about what you
see today as the sort of on-the-ground
issues with the way in which populations
are organized between cities suburbs and
rural areas I think the main problem is
that the suburbs are a living
arrangement with no future
we're simply you know not going to have
the resources to live that way but a lot
of people don't realize that the way our
cities are organized too will prove to
be problematic that in fact they have
they have grown far too big they're
they're outs they are out scaling what
will be the resource realities of the
future and they're gonna have to
contract and the contraction is going to
be pretty disorderly and you know I
think we're going to see a whole new
disposition of how people live in
America and a lot of it will include the
resurgence of small towns small cities
places that have a meaningful
relationship with agriculture because
that's going to become a much more
important issue as you know oil and gas
based industrial agriculture gets into
trouble well some of the advocates of
this new urbanization would say it's not
so much that the cities will have to
scale down but the cities will have to
build a direct relationship to
agriculture whether its rooftop farms or
vertical farming within cities etc what
about that possibility that it's not
ending that's a misunderstanding of how
reality works explain well you know
there is such a thing as gardening that
can take place in the urban setting but
you know one of the unfortunate
consequences of the suburban fiasco is
that it
our cultural memory of the distinction
between what's the town and what's the
country and there are certain there are
certain activities that are specific to
both and you know we're gonna have to do
the farming and the food production in
the place that is not the city and the
cities are gonna have to get smaller so
I I just disagree with that all idea
what about the future of the suburb
that's something I'm interested in as
well I mean we've talked with other
experts about how suburbs are sort of
fundamentally designed to depend on
vehicles to depend on driving to sort of
stymie community creation except sort of
in the most forced and concocted ways
just by their very layout what about the
possibility or is there a possibility of
turning suburbs into small towns as
independent from the cities that they
surround well I think that there is a
wish that we could somehow retrofit them
I don't think the money is going to be
there to do that you know I think that
the suburbs really have three destinies
ruins
salvaged and slums and you know not much
beyond that and it's you know it's
unfortunate life is tragic and sometimes
we have to pay the consequences of
making bad choices and we've made some
very bad choices in this country you
know it's funny because there's a
program at MIT now which is kind of a an
offshoot of the Harvard landscape
urbanism program and the MIT program is
putting out a lot of propaganda about
the future of the suburb as a nirvana of
self-driving cars and and
computerization and this is the kind of
techno narcissism that I think is is
really going to get us into trouble
because you know the societies are
really emergent and self-organizing and
they have to comply with the mandates of
reality and I think we're gonna find
ourselves in a pretty bad collision with
reality in the years ahead talk a little
bit about your work new urbanism
and
you might see a sort of the prescription
going forward to better organize the
ways in which humans are organizing
around cities and suburbs and small
towns
well the newer urbanism arose in the
early 1990s as a reform movement among a
group of Architects urban designers
municipal officials developers it was a
pretty broad group of professionals who
recognized I think rightfully that the
American suburb was a real fiasco and
that if we didn't figure out another way
to live on this on this continent that
we were gonna you know our civilization
was really going to get into trouble and
they dove into the dumpster of history
and they retrieved a lot of information
and methodology and principle for
traditional urban design you know most
of this stuff is a methods of designing
and assembling places for people to live
that is a human habitat that had been
successful for you know centuries if not
thousands of years and many of the basic
principles haven't changed you know that
the design and detailing of a street the
understanding that the buildings have to
have to form outdoor public rooms that
are comprehensible that make people feel
comfortable the idea that the places we
live have to be have to work with our
human neurology and you know they said
about to to you know prove their point
they built a lot of new town
developments around the United States
and also in in Europe and Asia but I
think their main contribution was the
recoating
of municipal laws all over America to
avert mandating the suburban sprawl out
outcome which had been embedded in in
law and custom and building practice and
really all of the relationships that
exist in the property development
industry well that really gets not a
question I have about this
which is is the solution you're talking
about zoning essentially do you see the
solution is coming from the top down in
that way I mean is there something the
individual can do well no the solution
is probably not going to come from the
top down I'm because that it is the
nation it's in the nature of emergence
that you know that just doesn't happen
what has happened is that as many
younger people have moved into the
planning profession you know they
they've realized that the suburban
mandates are insane and and you know
they they have joined the new urbanist
movement and in fact a lot of new
urbanist practice has now become you
know normal across the country but you
know the old habits die hard and there
are a lot of places especially in the
Midwest and the west where you know we
were still entertaining techno
narcissistic fantasies about the eternal
endless suburb so where do you live I
mean generally speaking not like your
address but but sort of where have you
chosen to live and how does that fit
into your views well I grew up in
Manhattan by the way you know and in the
center of the New York City so I've
experienced that but I'm living in a an
old factory village in upstate New York
200 miles from New York City and you
know it's a it's a small town that has
the bones of the old economy but a lot
of the old economy is gone but you know
I think that these are that are the
kinds of places that will have a much
bigger role in America's future because
these are the place that I live in is a
place that still does have a
relationship with with agriculture a
meaningful one and it also has you know
the the bones of a small urban place
that is scaled to the realities of the
future so so I'm very optimistic about
what will happen with small-town America
and small city America I think we ought
to be very concerned about what our
gonna you know what will happen with the
great Metroplex cities because they are
they're really going to hit the wall
hard and you know when that happens
gonna be a very disorderly process we've
been speaking with James Howard Kunstler
you can check out his twice weekly blog
and podcasts at consular comm and of
course all issues that no matter where
you live there's there's really no way
to say I'm not going to participate in
this problem but by definition you were
part of this because you live somewhere
a very important and super interesting
thanks for talking to me about it
quite welcome thank you the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
Donald Trump seems to believe Lattimer
Putin over our own intelligence agencies
although he's now trying to sort of
distance himself from that statement
while still saying that he believes why
do mere Putin it's a very weird thing
and this happened during Donald Trump's
trip to Asia we've been covering his
trip he had that bizarre stop in Japan
he had that strange foreign policy
speech in South Korea and then he had a
meeting with Russian President Vladimir
Putin in Vietnam that was sort of
unusual to say the least and as you know
the position of American intelligence
agencies has been for a very long time
now that Russia interfered in the 2016
election with the goal of helping Donald
Trump defeat Hillary Clinton right that
that's been the the consensus opinion of
American intelligence 'yes Putin has
previously and again to trump in Vietnam
just a couple of days ago said we didn't
medal and Trump apparently believes
Vladimir Putin here's a transcript from
Trump's conversation with a reporter
about this a reporter said did Russia's
attempt to meddle in u.s. elections come
up in the conversations with Putin of
course Trump said he said he didn't
meddle
he said he didn't meddle I asked him
again you can only ask so many times and
the reporter said today and Trump said I
just asked him again he said he
absolutely did not meddle in our
election he did not do what they are
saying he did and the reporter said on
election meddling did you ask him the
question and Trump said every time he
sees me he says I didn't do that and I
really believed that when he tells me
that he means it there are some really
specific questions that need asking
right like for example how do you know
President Trump
whether you should believe a hostile
foreign leader over your own
intelligence assessments or can you tell
us other times where you take the word
of a foreign leader over our
intelligence agencies is this the only
time or do you do it
other times as well what do you believe
has made our intelligence agencies so
untrustworthy if that's what you believe
that they are and of course after the
fact when an understandable amount of
chaos started when Trump said hey I
basically believe Putin despite what our
intelligence agencies have said
Trump tried to distance himself from
these comments which is a known strategy
for Trump right you say something if
people react negatively you deny ever
having said it and we have a quote from
Donald Trump at a news conference with
the Vietnamese president where he said
as to whether I believe it or not I'm
with our agencies especially as constant
as currently constituted as currently
led by fine people I believe very much
in our intelligence agencies now this is
such a weasel way of getting out of this
what on earth is that about you might be
saying what he has cut as constituted
currently Trump is basically going back
to his prior claims that the assessments
before from our intelligence agencies
couldn't be believed because you had
what he described as political hacks
running our Intel and Trump actually
said during this conversation with the
reporters a few days ago so you look at
it I mean you have former CIA director
John Brennan you have former Director of
National Intelligence James clapper and
you have former FBI director Jim Comey
Comey is proven now to be a liar and he
has proven now to be a leaker so you
look at that and you have President
Putin very strongly vehemently says he
had nothing to do with them so he's
basically saying what he says about
every American agency right the
Congressional Budget Office or the
Bureau of Labor Statistics whoever under
Obama when they said anything positive
about Obama's economy definitely
couldn't be trusted under Trump well if
they say good things about Trump's
economy then they can be trusted if they
say bad things then it's political
hackery
it's the exact same thing and I know
that this isn't proof that Donald Trump
is compromised but this is exactly how a
president that is compromised by Russia
would be acting right to take their word
over his own intelligence agencies but
then to say that now that I've taken
over the intelligence agencies and my
people are there instead of the previous
people they can be trusted and of course
this goes to a total lack of
understanding of how these intelligence
agencies work right James clapper John
Brennan deep these are people with very
long careers that involve working for
both Democrats and Republicans
Ekans both of those individuals
considered to be trustworthy and
respectable and not political hacks by
both Republican and Democratic
administrations and the mere idea that
Trump is floating here the
politicization of our intelligence
agencies is so problematic and of course
it's mostly problematic because he seems
to although he's kind of trying to
backtrack believe Vladimir Putin over
the best assessments the consensus
assessments of multiple American
intelligence agencies that yes happened
during the transition period between
President Barack Obama and President
Donald Trump scary scary stuff the
broader question is is Donald Trump more
generally being played or manipulated or
compromised by Russia two former
intelligence chiefs believe so
former Chiefs of American intelligence
agencies as well as Republican Senator
John McCain believe that Donald Trump is
putting the America the American people
and the United States itself in danger
in fact peril was the word that they
used former Director of National
Intelligence James clapper and former
CIA director John Brennan responded to
Donald Trump recently calling them
political hacks as I told you about
earlier on today's program because they
believe their own intelligence
effectively we have a quote from John
Brennan the former CIA director who said
it demonstrates to mr. Putin that Donald
Trump can be played by foreign leaders
who were going to appeal to his ego and
try to play upon his insecurities which
is a very very worrisome from a national
security standpoint former DNI James
clapper perfectly building on this ego
element of what's going on James clapper
saying I think he meaning Trump seems
very susceptible to rolling out the red
carpet honor guards and all the
trappings and pomp and circumstance that
come with the office I think that
appeals to him and it plays to his
insecurities yes I do think that both
the Chinese and the Russians can play
him and Republican Senator John McCain
also Bigley disturbed by Trump's recent
comments saying quote President Trump
today stated that he believed flat Amir
Putin is being sincere when he denies
Russian interference in the 2016
presidential
election and reiterated that he hopes to
cooperate with Russia and Syria
there's nothing America first about
taking the word of a KGB colonel over
that of the American intelligence
community Vladimir Putin does not have
America's interest at heart to believe
otherwise is not only naive but also
places our national security at risk the
reaction from the right ideally would be
wait wait hold on a second serious
respected intelligence officials who
work to keep us safe for years and years
top officials are saying this maybe we
should listen nope they're just
political hacks wait wait wait a
respected Republican senator who is not
known for hyperbole who is not known for
extremism in his beliefs not a guy I
agree with on many issues but not known
as a hyperbolic guy John McCain he's
concerned about what he sees maybe we
should listen now he's off his meds he's
a crazy old man or even worse things
about his brain cancer the big picture
is that Trump respects those who respect
him full-stop Trump panders to those who
he sees as pandering to him any
reasonably intelligent person and Putin
is one for sure right knows by now
exactly how to manipulate Donald Trump
and Trump's ego his inability to have
real friendships his entire personality
complex makes him very manipulative that
there is no doubt whatsoever that
Vladimir Putin is an expert in and
that's how you get Trump and others
falling for this but why would it be bad
to have better relations with other
countries that's all that's going on
that's one of those statements that in a
literal sense isn't wrong look yeah it's
generally better to have relationships
with other countries but it misses the
disturbing reality of why Trump thinks
that that's what he's working towards
with Vladimir Putin and the scariest
part of all this is that Trump may be
the victim in Trump Russia collusion
rather than the perpetrator which
wouldn't make it any less dangerous for
American national security will we ever
find out the truth I don't know
hopefully I know that I'm still
of naively holding out hope that we'll
get the full story at some point from
robert muller we will see we've got a
voicemail number that number is two one
nine two david p here's a voicemail that
came in recently
hey david this one let's know your
complete idiot from the best things
happen to this country in a long time
right and now you idiots just want to
shut it down you're stupid you're stupid
yeah i don't really have to comment on
this one but i would be interested to
know what specific policy achievements
has donald trump passed that the caller
thinks is evidence that Donald Trump is
doing more good for us than anyone in
recent history I don't remember the
exact language that he used I'd be
interested to hear what policies Trump
is has executed that you really like on
the bonus show today comedian louis c.k
admits to sexual misconduct and a number
of media companies are cutting ties with
him as well a new study suggests that
women are less likely to receive CPR
from bystanders very interesting data
and also a woman climbs through a
drive-thru window at mcdonald's and
assaults the McDonald's worker over none
other than Chicken McNuggets you know if
it was one of those shakes I could
understand jumping through a window and
ringing someone's neck at McDonald's but
the chicken nuggets are quite frankly
not that good so that that's a weird
story that we're gonna delve into on
today's bonus show how do you access the
bonus show well there's two ways number
one you get a membership at david
pakman.com slash membership if you want
a discount the coupon code is I voted
seventeen second option for membership
is contribute at the $5 a month level at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
nearly 2100 of you have now contributed
on patreon and for every two patreon
contributors I will remove one piece
from the Jenga tower and as you can see
and Pat looks very scared every time I
gesture near it because it is on its
last leg we have made 26 moves here from
52 different patrons meaning that if the
tower were to fall before I'm able to
make another
move that will trigger a 56 52 percent
discount code off of membership 26
pieces means 52% off if I can move a few
more pieces tomorrow or the next day the
discount will be approaching 60 percent
which is stunning Pat will pick up a
couple hundred thousand memberships if
we do that so very very exciting
patreon.com slash david packard show
david pakman.com slash membership I will
speak to you briefly momentarily on the
bone
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]